makes your breath bacon fresh I could
only imagine how putrid my breath must
bow right now I was raised kosher and
then I became a vegetarian for a lot of
years so I've actually had very little
bacon eating time in my life I don't
want to taste like it's good smells good
tastes good just not a fan of meat and
pigs I mean I do miss bacon who the hell
doesn't miss bacon I thought that was a
big face that they did but now they have
big bacon stuff so who cares so I guess
these are crackers that have been imbued
with the spirit of bacon smells like
really fatty fatty bacon
this really isn't made with honey it's
just like this interesting the bacon is
subtle I feel like it smells more bacony
than it tastes
it's good I imagine the person that
wants this is also the person that like
gets mad at me for not eating me even if
I didn't bring it up oh I have wool fake
bacon chunks in the chocolate bacon bits
vegetarian I've had plenty of those oh
there's even a little fake fat in there
it's crunchy if someone gave this to me
I wouldn't even like pinpoint the bacon
flavor at all
[Music]
there the color oh oh whoa tastes like
pee it's like a mix of mint and smoky
bacon flavor I'm getting it
it's smoky I'm possible to blow a bubble
with this no kinda cool snot bubble at
the same time they put this muffle it
looks like normal hit this like there's
no red stripe which is nice
sure cool shut your fall to do cut out
my tongue this doesn't taste like bacon
it just tastes like mint mixed with some
sort of weird like smoky flavor this is
just dog things repurposed as human
things maybe this is what I dog doesn't
like getting her teeth brush there's an
aftertaste of bacon a little bit I feel
like it would be smart for a dentist to
approve it if it does prevent cavities
let's say you have a little kid who will
brush their teeth but I love bacon to
get some bacon toothpaste
oh my dentists is watching oh okay
you're gonna have breath of any sort and
it's not minty Bacon's not a horrible
option I think this could fool someone
into thinking of this is what bacon
tastes like if they haven't eat eating
it and longer than I have
I think I've realized there today none
of these products have made me either
yearn for more bacon in my life nor more
bacon flavor in my life if I was at all
missing meat before this experience I am
so happy with just cutting it out
[Music]
you